sage dafür dass es im leben eines jeden
ponys mal die musik und ihr ist schon
freundschaft gibt ihr seid ja verrückt
heute hier zu einem löffel und zwar ein
zeichentrickfilm das heißt ein teil ist
er wirklich gezeichnet nur zum teil
gepixelt und programmiert und da geht es
um sechs pferde und ein kleinen drachen
fertigen eigentlich genauer ponys die
ihre auf freundschaft und gegenseitigen
respekt und wir sind verschieden aber
gleichberechtigt errichtete kultur und
zivilisation gegen einen grundlosen
affen verteidigen also in dem film geht
es darum dass diese friendship ist magic
welt in der es im wesentlichen darum
geht dass diese von ist alle verschieden
sind aber gleichberechtigt und die
kriegen es aber irgendwie hin
miteinander auf dieser basis also
arbeitsteilung aber weitgehend ohne
hierarchie selbst wenn jemand mal
anführerin ist denn es sind überwiegend
weg mädchen also man hält sich an dem
ärzte song die welt in der alle menschen
mädchen wären statt alle menschen werden
brüder wie die französische revolution
sich das dachte wo sich ja nur die köpfe
abschlagen von also es mit den mädchen
funktioniert besser funktioniert aber
nur so lange bis der affe eben kommt der
ihnen ihre magie stehlen will sie dann
auch noch aus dem land schmeißen und
sohn dann müssen sie eine koalition
bilden
zwischen verschiedenen anderen
geschädigten dieses affen denn der affe
hatten ganz schön zart eine schneise der
verwüstung und verblödung sozusagen
durch diese welt gezogen und das
schaffen sie auch diese koalition zu
schmieden und vielleicht kann man das ja
auch als erwachsener mensch dann
irgendwann brauchen solche koalitionen
zu schmieden gegen schwachsinn und
brutalität die in irgendeiner form das
leben vermisst
da gibt es sechs sehr wichtige haupt
ponys nein darüber muss man jetzt nicht
lachen weil es gibt ja auch vier
wichtige pilzköpfe aus liverpool und
solche leute das findet ihr auch jeder
wichtig oder wer bei dallas mit wem
verwandt ist
die sechs sind und das muss ich hier
ausdrücklich sagen flattert eine gelbe
tierschützerin [ __ ] eine rosa party
bombe werritty eine schneeweiße
modedesignerin princes twilight sparkle
das ist die intellektuelle in der gruppe
a rainbow dash ist noch sehr wichtig ist
die abenteurerin und apple jack das ist
die sehr bodenständige farmerin und dann
gibt es noch den drachen smaug der der
chefin nämlich der intellektuellen ist
ein fernseh wir ja eigentlich meine juni
friendships magic beruht eigentlich auf
eine kunst trennten sache nämlich der
konzern hasbro der spielzeughersteller
plüschtieren plastikfiguren usw hat sich
geschichten bestellt damit die sachen
besser verkauft werden können und die
beziehung zwischen 70 uhren
ich mache eine kindlich reichhaltige
fernsehserie ungefähr auf dem
qualitätslevel von sagen wir mal game of
thrones oder brechen bett bisschen
interessanter natürlich weil erwachsene
sind ja sehr schematische leute während
kinder viel chaotischer sind weswegen
die sehr viel interessanter ist als die
beiden anderen ich genannt habe aber die
sind ja auch ganz gut
besonders erstaunlich findet man es
offenbar dass jungs so etwas eigentlich
mädchen erschien es in irgendeiner form
gut finden deswegen werden die brawnies
genannt von brother pro und ponys da
wird ein ziemliches gewesen darum
gemacht ist aber alles gar nicht so
schlimm weil man kann beispielsweise
auch ein typ sein sich nicht als bonnie
fühlen und auch nicht in der branche
subkultur drin sein und trotzdem
begeistert von dieser sache sein sowie
nicht alle leute die game of thrones
mögen aus hunden trinken
[Musik]
auf jeden fall geeignet für leute die
von ihrer kunst nicht unbedingt zwingend
langeweile erwarten das ist ziemlich
schnell das geht anderthalb stunden und
diese ganzen quatsch köpfe in hollywood
die zwei stunden filme machen in denen
im grunde eigentlich nichts los ist
außer alles sollten sich an diesem film
echten ein beispiel nehmen
[Musik]